I want to thank Dr Morrison for his
invitation to talk with you today
and I was very happy to share the
classes on Tuesday which gave me a real
sense of what this class is about and
what what it's like and in particular
his comments a very very learned
comments I want to say I was very
impressed with his grasp of Wittgenstein
and about whom I think I know something
and
um also I was very very enlightened by
what he had to say about William James
I had just I've just come from New
Hampshire where I spent Thanksgiving
and uh that gave me a sense of the where
William James sent spent his last days
last years I think yeah
um a beautiful beautiful country you
have here
all my America is so wonderful
um
anyway uh
speaking of Wittgenstein who was this
man Connor one of her so kind of drury's
teacher
Wittgenstein wasn't terribly
impressed by these classes
he says my lectures are going well
they will never go better
but what effects do they leave behind
am I helping anybody
what day his students learn is not worth
learning
and the personal impression I make does
not serve them
with anything
that's true for all of them
with perhaps one or two exceptions
so I'm looking around the class now to
see who the exceptions are going to be
however I think it's evident that a
decent wittgenstein's case
in Cambridge University in England
far more than one or two students were
deeply
affected by his classes
and very prominent among these was
Morris O'Connell Drury
um that's a picture of him here
I didn't bring
um all the equipment you know the bells
and whistles uh with you because at any
lecture I've been in Ireland anyway in
the last couple of years
the pictures broke down the uh the
computers
just just don't work and in my age group
I'm just not as enough of a Tech head to
control that
so this Mars O'Connor jewelry is is a
central figure
that I want to discuss with you today
and white jewelry here in this class
it's clear that jury is relevant to
medicine and the humanities homes zero
two nine
like most figures discussed
in this class Drury was a physician he
was a doctor
but he wrote a highly regarded book
about medical practice from a humanistic
perspective
he was an undergraduate student a
philosophy at Cambridge University
they didn't call it philosophy at
Cambridge they call it the moral
sciences
and he was tutored by Wittgenstein
uh Drury had originally intended to take
orders in the Anglican Church
um in America here that's the
Episcopalian community
rejecting that plan he aspired to a
career teaching philosophy
but was Guided by Wittgenstein towards
medicine instead
and Wittgenstein continued with a
mentoring role towards jury's medical
education in Dublin in the late 1930s
through his early years as a doctor in
the broad the royal
the British royal Army Medical Corps
during World War II and he recommended
that after the war Drury should
specialize in Psychiatry which truly did
so this man had a huge influence on his
life
um on drury's life
despite a very busy professional life
Drury persisted in being deeply involved
in philosophy
bringing to Bear what he'd learned from
Wittgenstein in particular to issues
that arose in the practice of his
Psychiatry and we were going to talk
about that
my own involvement in this story is that
I've assembled his writings
previously published and unpublished in
this book this latest writings of
Maurice O'Connor Drury and I think I
mentioned to you last day it's published
by the same publisher as Harry Potter
so that's my big claim to fame
the collection justifies considering him
alongside the physician writers that are
featured in your course
Henry Marsh
and Lisa Sanders of the Yale medical
school
all have are our deploying perspectives
informed by the humanities to enrich
Medical Practice
and actually the last day uh
Dr Morrison asked me
to explain why the humanities
and I think the humanities
role is to
Foster or take care of your soul
and what do I mean by your soul
the Latin for the soul is anima
so it's what animates you
what makes you alive
when you cry when you smile when you're
with friends when you're with love
it's your soul
it's uh so we have soul music
it's It's a Wonderful World
and the humanities
Foster that that's what they're there
you read a novel you read the poem you
listen to music
you take part in the play
you you are at Play You Dance
it's it's it's that's what the humanity
it's it's your human what you can do as
a human being and to Foster and
strengthen that
so Drury understood that humanistic
insights
and valuable for medical practice was
not confined to be subject philosophy
and then that doctors and indeed all of
those who have a concern for home
medicine is practiced in Civil Society
generally
could gain from reading and I quote from
him the great novelists like Tom story
the dramatists
biographers and historians
the person who brought brought Brothers
here this morning is is about to is a
theater director and in Rhode Island
Providence and she's just starting next
week on a play called the the faith
healers and I would absolutely love to
be a kind of
a gopher with her you know seeing how a
play how you put a play together
is extraordinary
now it seems to me that this is the
thesis is that underlies this course
that medicine
is the most think about this this is a
quotation in the most humanistic of the
Sciences
and
uh
the most scientific of the humanities
it straddles it straddles medicine
properly practiced
is the most humanistic of the sciences
and the most scientific of the
humanities
um as I've already said the predominant
philosophical influence on Drury was
wittenstein
and Wittgenstein is regarded
along with Martin Heidegger
as the most Innovative philosophers of
the 20th century and as I become clear
to you Wilkinson had a profound interest
in medicine and the focus of his meds of
his interest in medicine was Drury and
his career
but also also that Martin Heidegger the
German philosopher philosopher
philosophy is kind of divided into two
um
uh styles of philosophy the anglophone
philosophy which was what you would
probably mainly get here in any
English-speaking country like England
Ireland America Canada Australia you
know the the former
British Empire and um but Heidegger also
had a huge interest in medicine
he was based in Germany
and he gave raise to what's called
phenomenological philosophy
and uh for 10 years no he he really did
spot his copy book during the second
world war because he was um he kind of
collaborated with the Nazis
in the University system
um and he said but he did have this
seminar in Switzerland after the war for
about 10 years called the zalikon
seminars
and it was mainly for doctors and mainly
psychiatrists and philosophers
and one of his quotations just I'm now
going to spend a lot of time with him
but he said blood pressure can be
measured
but not life pressures
you can measure your blood pressure I
can do it on my watch
it's probably zooming right now and but
not your life pressures what's really
bothering you
heart functioning can be measured
but not the loss of heart
or heartbreak
um
and he focused on the patient's
experience of disease in the form of
pain or discomfort
emotional
distress and depression
but that in itself is not anything
measurable
and of course science has to do with
what measurable
one cannot measure tears
measures at best affluid
but
the drops of the fluid are not the tears
I think it's a beautiful
way of putting it that's that's I'm
going to move away from Heidegger but we
could have another talk about the
influence of Heidegger on medicine
it's widely accepted that a journal kept
by Drury as a student later published as
conversations with Wittgenstein has
contributed the most compelling picture
of Wittgenstein available
he was a Magnetic Personality
he attracted interests and has attracted
interest fire outside the confines of
professional philosophy
I don't know if you're familiar with the
um with the film dancing at lunasa
which involves
um Meryl Streep
as playing the main thing the the author
of that play originally Brian Friel
contacted me once to say I would like to
write a play about Wittgenstein in
Ireland
and of course I was very excited my 15
moments of Fame had arrived
and then he invited me to the famous
theater in the Abbey theater in Dublin
and everybody was there from the
president of the country the for a in
his new play called give me your answer
do
I don't know if you know the little song
say Daisy Daisy give me your answer do
anyway that was the name play and I was
waiting with baited breath to have him
talk about you know how the characters
talk about Wittgenstein but the play
turned out to be about a playwright who
could not write a play about wittenstein
so there you are
um but if it concise personality has
attracted to enormous enormous amount of
of Interest outside of philosophy
and the standard biography of
Wittgenstein by a man called Ray Monk
called Ludwig Wittgenstein the duty of
Genius
was written has written that it was
drury's journal the conversations which
we can Stein that first stimulated him
to imagine a biography of Wittgenstein
what struck among was how jury's
accounts contrasted so vividly
with the pale shadow of the real man
prevailed that prevailed in Oxford in
the late 1980s by that time wickenstein
was dead 10 15 years and monk was a
student of philosophy at the University
and actually he introduced this book and
described how as a student in he had
gone off to London for the weekend he
bought the journals
a copy of wickenstein's journals he said
I read it all the way up
to do on the bus back up to Oxford and
I at that moment I decided to write a
biography of Wittgenstein
and this authenticity
is found not only in in Rudy's Journal
but also in essays which concentrated on
the philosophical problems that arise in
Psychiatry and psychology which have
been collected in drury's book they were
originally talks to
groups of doctors in Dublin and Swansea
in England in Wales and he then produced
in the danger of words
and monk again wrote that in its coal in
its tone and its concerns it was perhaps
the most truly vicenstinian work
published by any of the concerned
students
with all that in mind I propose to tell
you a little more about Drury and his
relationship with Wittgenstein our
relationship that lasted from 1931 when
he first met him as a student until
wittgenstein's death in 1951 over 20
years
and now however as a preliminary to that
account I think it would be helpful to
situate the Wittgenstein jury
interaction as a relatively modern
instance of an interaction between
Western philosophy and medicine and I
say Western philosophy because and
Western medicine because there are also
wonderful medicines
uh Chinese medicines and Indian
medicines and medicines that are in
indigenous communities all over the
world I mean we we have just one version
of medicine but it's the one that in
this country in my own country uh
predominates
but that this goes back a very long way
the the interaction between medicine and
philosophy and Medicine back to
Classical Greece
um and the famous Christian writer
tertullian said it was like a Sisterhood
between the two
because one was a Quest For Truth
philosophy and the other was a quest for
health
but sometimes truth can be understand
understood as critical to
health
mental health in particular
so this is why I'm I'm going to bring
you a passage illustrating all of this
from one of Plato's dialogues the laws
and it's in front of you here no
he says a state's invalides include not
only free men but slaves too as you know
there was in slaves were an integral
part of
Dutch of ancient Greece
and the state's invalids who are not
free but slaves
are always being treated by other slaves
who either Rush about on flying visits
or wait to be consulted in their
surgeries
now apparently some people speculate
that this may have been written at the
time of a plague in Athens
this kind of doctor
the slave doctor
never gives any account of the
particular in illness of the individual
slave
R is prepared to listen to one
he simply prescribes what he thinks best
in the light of experience as if he had
precise knowledge and with the
self-confidence of a dictator
I'm telling you what to do
then he dashes off on his way to the
next snave's patient and so takes off
his master's shoulders some of the work
of attending the sick
I don't know if you think this but this
is so contemporary it's unbelievable
the visits of the free doctor by
contrast are mostly concerned with
treating the illnesses of free men
his method
is to construct an empirical case
history by Consulting the invalid and
his friends
in this way he himself learns something
from the sick
and at the same time he gives the
individual patient all the instructions
he can
he gives no prescription until he has
somehow gained the invalid's consent
then coaxing him into continued
cooperation he tries to complete his
restoration to health
now which of the two methods is best
used by The Physician or director of
bodily regime of regiment
regimen I think is what I should say
there
the trainer the physical trainer was
very important in
ancient Greece
as important as a doctor
so the you know the man who who for
example like a physiotherapist
but somebody who kind of you if you go
to a gym and work work you you know
helps you to work yourself out work out
um he said that which affects the same
result by a two-fold process
or that which implies a single process
the worst of the two and exasperated
subject what that means is
the guy who just hands out prescriptions
that's one method the guy who listens to
his patient and examines him correctly
that's another
and you need to do both
now as the French say Plus
shows it is not is it not still the case
not far too frequently cursory Hasty and
therefore not thorough or detailed or
respectful Medical Care is suspense to
the poor
while the economically endowed demand
and get considered considerate and
considered care
and this situation raised the
philosophical question that motivated
all of that concerns all of excuse me
Plato's investigations
can that State of Affairs be
qualify as socially just
while it is true that Plato did not ask
which he should have done the question
about the institution of slavery
I don't think there is more on up to
date or more fundamental class question
to be asked of society now and I base
this on on talking a lot to doctors to
nurses to occupational therapists to
physiotherapists all sorts of people the
medical system certainly in Ireland and
also in England is under tremendous
pressure
and the people who get the worst end of
the state are of course the economically
the private people
and indeed as I mentioned last day an
influential group of
philosophers all female
argued in Oxford for the continued
importance of values
in running Society especially the value
of justice and fairness
um
so I'll just I think I've talked about
them the last day but they have they
have they succeeded to introduce a new
form of a new take on ethics
uh which argued against the idea that if
it feels good for me well it's okay
that's it that's all that's the end of
it
if I feel good about it
okay
Dave what they were saying is uh it has
to be based on
certain values behaviors that contribute
to your own goodness but also to those
of others we do not live
as our isolated automatons we live in a
social
situation
and
in that we find our fulfillment
now you may query how it is that
philosophers still draw inspiration from
ancient texts from like Plato's
dialogues which have just been
discussing with you and indeed what
started out as Aristotle's notes upon
about which these female philosophers
base themselves
and during discussed this practice
explicitly in his letters
and he found his answer in The Perennial
nature of philosophy and I've got
the he found the point elaborated in
another one of Plato's dialogues The
Republic
and here you see it here dialectic
philosophical interrogation
in fact is the only activity whose
method is to challenge its own
assumptions so that it may rest firmly
on first principles
where the eye of the mind gets really
bogged down in a morass of ignorance
dialectic gently pulls it out and bleeds
it
so the Socratic method of asking
questions what do you mean
and
then you give an answer and they say
what do you mean by that
and what do you mean by meaning
the contribution of philosophy is
actually the same in every generation
that's why
what has the answers that came before
you know are still relevant
um and it is to Foster an individual's
interrogation and that concludes every
one of you
of your of your own and in particular
our cultural assumptions
by that I mean the assumptions that come
from us that we come almost with our
mother's milk
the kind of things that that are assumed
in your family
in your high school
in your University
and we're we normally are not aware of
that unless we interrogate it
and Drury believed that a medical
education and practice for example
is not exhausted by the accumulation of
information and experience particularly
information it's not a question of
learning learning about every drug and
every
um you know bodily organ and about the
interaction thereof it requires
something more
the willingness to question Medical
Practice in terms of the values I
suppose in his performance in other
words to ask questions about the
questions that medicine asks
because a doctor coming into his
Consulting rooms
brings with it the kind of
um a suite of assumptions and questions
but maybe he's not asking the right
questions
I once asked I had an Ivan an uncle he's
now dead but he was a farmer
and I used to spend a lot of time with
him on the farm
and uh much later I asked him
do you think I would have made a good
farmer
and he said no and I said why I said why
he said you were asking the wrong
questions
when you were aged five
you have to you have to ask the right
questions to be a good firm you have to
ask the right questions to be a good
doctor and to ask these questions is a
philosophical
interrogation
now you will notice that in the excerpt
from the laws which we read about the
about the interstate's invalides
uh
Plato commends the free man's doctor
who constructs an empirical case history
by Consulting the invalid and his
friends in this way he himself learns
something from the sick and at the same
time he gives the individual patient all
the instruction he can
in commending this approach plays with
the philosopher is referencing a
fundamental Medical Institution
the clinical interview
the formal conversation between doctor
and patients
and evidence of its Greek Origins can be
found in the very words we still use to
describe the phases of that interview
you have that down here now
taking a history
the Greek for that is animesis
which is the very
Medical Practice singled out by Plato as
characteristic of and worthy of a free
man attentive listening to the patient's
story stroke narrative
I note the emphasis placed on this phase
by Grande and Sanders and it appears in
Drury too and indeed it is the case that
the dialogue between Doctrine patient
plays an especially
Central healing role in Drury specialty
psychiatry
much more important than the fields
the second is an examination
using in addition to hearing
the senses of sight
yeah and touch
so you go on the couch and you're you he
uses his fingers his hands
to um
to help him to reconstruct an empirical
case history
Greek medicine and his apogee which in
best in the Greek Dr Galen of pergamon
which is Turkey
he practiced in Rome was characterized
by the recording of clinical histories
for comparison's sake later on with the
intervention of the stethoscope in 1826
the range of such examinations are
considerably increased and of course is
now later
augmented by comprehensive laboratory
tests to the extent however as gwanda
claims that testing has overwhelmed
Medical Systems
it's all about testing
thirdly
in the medical interview is a diagnosis
using an anatomical and with the
development of history of medicine
physiology physiological and
pathological models
modern medicine relied on such medicine
can be dated to 1858 with the
publication of the book by Rudolf virtue
of called cellular pathology
however I know Professor Saunders view I
saw that what I thought of as diagnosis
was wrong much of the time or for the
most exciting Parts in any case I found
that diagnosis was not the
multiplication tables or the application
of an algorithm but more like Sherlock
Holmes this Insight faces us with the
presence of uncertainty in medical
investigation
which means that there can never be
simply applying an algorithm
that view is reinforced by similar
insights into scientific investigation
itself even sketching stretching to the
level of quantum physics and I think I
mentioned the book last day that does
that
fourthly there's a prognosis
again a Greek word
and a preferred method of treatment
the goal of the clinical interview is to
arrive at a medical procedure that will
lead the embodied being very important
in philosophy they embodied being not a
defective machine
and that's of course where the problem
comes
we can understand machines
much better than we can understand human
beings
to be restored to health
the World Health Organization described
that as a state of complete physical
mental and social well-being and not
merely the absence of disease or
infirmity
now with that context sketched I want to
see how I'm doing for time
I am now in a position to relate more
jury's biography highlighting in
particular a letter where Wittgenstein
instructs Drury now a medical student
along lines which are strikingly can't
congruent with the Plato's critique of
current Medical Practice
Drury was born in Wiltshire in UK in
1907.
and um
as I said both these parents were
irish-born but Anglican Prince Anglican
Christians that's to say members of the
Church of England
and after his retirement to Exeter in
Devon khandwori went to the grammar
school there
while still at that high school we
that's
the modern equivalent of a grammar
school
he went up to Trinity College in
Cambridge in 1926 to study what was then
called the moral Sciences as I mentioned
that's philosophy with a long-term plan
to take Anglican orders
in drury's third year at Trinity
College in Cambridge Ludwig Wittgenstein
returned to Cambridge where he had
studied under Barton Russell that's we
were all mentioned the last day for some
years before the first world war to
teach philosophy
uh he was immediately fell under
rickenstein's spell and thereafter
almost all the vocational decisions in
his life were strongly influenced if not
dominated
by his teacher
hence although he resisted wittenstein's
Council to abandon his plan to enroll in
the Anglican theological college at
Cambridge Westcott House
because Frankenstein claimed that
clerical color would choke you
um Drury left the Seminary after a year
in fact and then he followed
rickenstein's advice to live among
Ordinary People
um
vidconstein was very strongly he
reconcile himself had come from probably
the richest family in Austria
and he gave away all his after returning
from the first world war he gave away
all his money to his brothers and
sisters
and out thereafter he lived very very
frugally
and you have mentioned last day that the
number of different kind of things he
tried School teaching
gardening architecture God knows
but anyway in Drew's case he was
involved in schemes to assist the vast
number of unemployed people in Britain
following the worldwide economic
depression of the 1930s which of course
affected life here in America as well
and wittenstein's advice was that such
voluntary work would be an antidote to
the two narrow confines of drury's
middle class English society which was
still affected by Victorian manners very
very proper
Vic design frequently expressed The View
that teaching philosophy what he was
doing himself was a ridiculous
profession
and so he was pleased when Rory failed
to be appointed to an academic Post in
philosophy when he applied for one about
this time
and a later a little later wickensteined
in view into
intervened when Drury who's still
needing to settle on a career was so
moved by the plight of a fellow worker
who had suffered a mental background
breakdown that he wrote to birkenstein
that he was considering becoming a
psychiatric nurse
wickenstein immediately suggested a
review of his level of Education jury
should instead instead enroll in a
medical school Drury said well I don't
have the money
wickenstein then went to his friend
Maynard Keynes the famous economist who
spent every morning in bed until 12
o'clock playing the stock market on his
telephone
and Keynes came up with the cash they
then settled on the medical school at
Trinity College in Dublin a very old
Medical School founded in 1711 maybe
slightly before Yale itself was founded
and
mainly on the basis that the fees there
were the cheapest they could find
and Dublin of course was during his
father's native City
uh during the course of Gloria's medical
studies Wittgenstein visited in Dublin
several times
and I will return to an incident that
happened during one of these visits
later on at one stage Wisconsin
Wittgenstein our story to inquire his
tutor at Trinity College Dublin whether
Wittgenstein might join him there to
study medicine
I requested not surprisingly was greeted
with astonishment be like a Yale
professor uh applying to some medical
school in New York Columbia maybe and
saying can I join can I become a doctor
uh you know it's extraordinary
the plan came to nothing but then
Wittgenstein also was thinking of going
to Russia and studying studying meds or
yeah studying medicine there
and you have to understand that that in
that case in that in that environment in
Oxford Cambridge
is the 1930s Marxism was very very
popular and a lot of the people there
were Communists and actually eventually
proved to be spies during the second
World War
uh and um
they they thought that Russia
represented the future
socialists Russia
hey
um here we are
if you could pass that down do you mind
could you pass it down please
so um
um
anyway
uh Vic Drury was quite was quite happy
with the scientific studies and became
forced in his class studying physiology
and you know biology and all that but
when he moved into the clinical phase of
his medical uh
education
he became he suffered a vocational
crisis
I can guarantee that you're going to
serve a vocational crisis at some stage
with her life maybe several of them
I can tell you that for nothing I've
been teaching students your age for 40
years and some of the most creative and
best of the people that changed our
minds
um anyway Dory was very despondent very
down in the dumps and uh Wittgenstein
wrote him a letter and this letter is
the OWN people I I archived all his
writings and everybody I mean they've
come from all over the world too
Limerick where I live and they're all
expected in the archive they're going to
find letters at wickenstein wrote
to Drury and we know that he wrote many
of them
and there's only one that survives
and I swear to God I haven't I'm not
concealing anything
that's only there's only one
and uh yeah
dear Drury I have thought a fair amount
about our conversation on Sunday
and I would like to say or rather not to
say but right
a few things about these conversations
mainly I think this
don't think about yourself
but think about others for example your
patience
you said in the Phoenix Park that's the
big Park in Dublin yesterday where they
spent a lot of time walking
that possibly you made a mistake having
taken up medicine
you immediately added that probably it
was wrong to think such a thing at all
I am sure it is
but not because being a doctor you may
not that that not because being a doctor
you may not go the wrong way or go to
the dogs
but because if you do this has nothing
to do with your choice of of a
profession being a mistake
for what a human being can say what
would have been the right thing if this
is the wrong one
you didn't make a mistake because there
was nothing at the time you knew or
ought to have known that you overlooked
you did your best
only this could have been called making
a mistake
and even if you made a mistake in this
sense this would now have to be regarded
as datum
as all the other circumstances inside
and outside which you can't alter
um the thing now is to live in the world
in which you are not to think of or
dream about the world you would like
to be in
look at people's sufferings
physical and mental
you have them close at hand
and this ought to be a good remedy for
your troubles
another way is to take a rest whenever
you ought to take one and collect
yourself
not with me because I wouldn't rest you
as religious thoughts I do not think the
craving for placidity
is religious
which is often how religion is sold
something one or two hunt after
look at your patients more closely as
human beings in trouble and enjoy more
of the opportunity you have to say good
night to many people
this alone is a gift from heaven
which may many people would envy you
and this sort of thing ought to heal you
and heal your friends soul I believe
it won't rest it but when you are
healthily tired you may you can just
take a rest
I think in some sense you don't look at
people's face the window of the Soul
closely enough
in conversations with me don't so much
try to have the conversations which you
think would taste well though you will
never get that anyway but try to have
the conversations which will have the
pleasantest aftertaste it is most
important that we should not one day
have to tell ourselves that we had
wasted the time we were allowed to spend
together
I wish you good thoughts but chiefly
good feelings
for my part I see many Echoes here of
Plato's contrast between Medical Care
worldview and Freeman and his implied
criticism of the kind of doctor who
never gave us any account of the
particular illness of the individual
slave or is prepared to listen to one
but simply prescribes what he thinks
um best in the lives of experience as if
he had precise knowledge and with the
self-confidence of a dictator that's the
end of the quote from Plato
uh immediately after the war after the
graduating Drury
joined the Royal Army Medical Corps and
he had a pretty rough time he had an
easy time in Egypt in Cairo but
afterwards he followed an attempted
Hospital the um
the advance of the army he on he was he
was landed on the beaches at Normandy
and Then followed the
the advance of the army the British army
across northern France and into Holland
and then the Battle of the Bulge in
which American soldiers distinguished
themselves greatly
and um he was in attended hospital and
um
it was rough going
he returned to Dublin after the war
after five years of service
during the war Wittgenstein himself
worked even though he was a professor of
philosophy in Cambridge he went up there
a day or two a week
but for the rest he worked in guys
Hospital in London as
a porter in the pharmaceutical assistant
which meant he went around the boards
bringing the medicines and then he got
involved in a research project regarding
shock
um shock that in came to people after
they had um
the bombing in London really I mean they
can think of the same thing in Kiev at
the moment
and Ukraine generally you know that it
does leave huge marks on the people who
have been bombed
and um
anyway he he never really settled in
philosophy after that point and
eventually he decided that he might
there was a book in him that he wanted
to write in the 1930s the book which he
never finished but was published
posthumously as the philosophical
investigations this is uh Wittgenstein
and so that there were two men in crisis
uh
and eventually Drury secured a six-month
contract in Saint Patrick's
philosophical hospital for Psychiatric
Hospital in Dublin which was actually
founded by Jonathan Swift to get the
writer of Gulliver's Travels
and uh and he actually stuck with
Psychiatry and uh
stay there until he retired with cardiac
related symptoms
he died on Christmas Day in 1976 that's
Drury
so Wittgenstein after retiring decided
would I go to Norway where they had a
hut
on a fjord or when I go to Ireland he
came back to Ireland and while there he
got a very very severe mental mentally
he became very severely mentally ill
and he was referred
by Drury to drury's bus
Professor Norman Moore
again we don't know an awful lot about
what the problem was but eventually he
went to the wildest part of of Ireland
Connemara
and Drew a cottage that drury's elder
brother had there
wickenstein died of prostatic cancer
cancer cancer
in 1951.
in the home of a medical friend of Drury
is Dr Bevin in Cambridge
now at the beginning I quoted from Plato
and I want a quote from Drury and about
an event
which took place a good deal earlier
in Dublin in 1936
Drew here called when I was a medical
student here in Dublin and Wittgenstein
came over to visit me
he wanted to give talks with some mental
patients
I arranged for him to go to St Patrick's
hospital as a psychiatric hospital as a
visit whenever he wanted to
there was one old man who had been in
the hospital for many years
and
wickenstein said about him he was much
more intelligent than his doctors
this man had read a lot of Herbert
Spencer that's the evolutionary theorist
and one day he had he was when he was
having a discussion with Wittgenstein I
was there too
and I attempted to join in with some
rather shallow logical positivism
which was the then fashionable
philosophy
in England further to a book by AJ AJ
air
which actually summarized
um Trends in philosophy which had
developed in Vienna
wittgenstein's home City
and very much influenced by African
cyber Frankenstein never ever agreed
that anybody could speak for him
so Wittgenstein told me to shut up
when he intervened when Drury intervened
in this discussion with the patient
later when he was talking about on our
own he said when you are playing ping
pong
you shouldn't use a tennis racket
in other words be sensitive now
amazingly Albert Camus have you ever
heard of him
a French writer
a philosopher extremely interesting man
as well
he tells a very similar story
but he has an interesting twist in it
because here
he said in a psychiatric hospital
a passing doctor noticed one of his
patients
fishing with a rod in a bathtub
imagine it
as he walked by mindful of this
indispensable partnership
between two human beings
the doctor asked the patient
are they biting
the fish in the bathtub
to which the patients replied idiot
can't you even see that it is a bathtub
so uh yeah
no
I have stressed very much that this all
depends on the store of experience
and the examined life that a doctor
brings to his patients
and by experience I think I can do
better than quote from one of
wittgenstein's favorite novelists
Dostoevsky
in the brothers karamatsov
it was said by many people about the
Elder zazima
that by permitting everyone
for so many years to come to Bear their
souls and hearts and beg his advice and
healing words
he had absorbed so many Secrets sorrows
and evolves into his soul
that in the end he required so final
perception that he could tell at the
first glance from the face of a stranger
what he had come for what he wanted and
what kind of Torment wrecked his
conscience
Wittgenstein is your Drury yes
there really have been people like that
and indeed I believe there are doctors
and other health professionals who can
read their patients as it were at a
glance
but unfortunately this is a facility
which is feigned in the reality
in reality
in in its absented in the slave Doctor
Who briskly proceeds from bed to bed and
pretends he can read the patient like
that
but there are people who can read
you can zoom in straight away no
we like one for just a few more minutes
I mentioned earlier that Drury collected
in the danger words a number of papers
either originally given mainly to groups
of doctors
as an illustration of the influence that
Wittgenstein had on on him
I notice here references to problems
practical difficulty and perplexity I
haven't given you the full quotation
by way of introduction to another facet
of the relationship between philosophy
and medicine that is much more
problematic than we have discussed so
far
that concerns the role of scientific
investigation in medicine
and that too had definite albeit not
exclusive origins in certain
philosophical trends
it's because of of the philosophy of the
physics
that
where they decided that um
there were four
um
Elementary subjects substances that go
to make up the world earth air fire and
water
this was reflected in the body
in four Elementary bodily fluids
phlegm yellow brile black bile and blood
all in dynamic balance
and well into the 19th century the
medical practice of bloodletting was
Justified on the pretext of restoring
the bodily fluids
that you if you if you had kind of a
I'm putting a flushed face
you should
some drug would be drawn by leeches
little animals
so
this this was actually in contravention
of what the Greek idea
of medicine was which was that one
should rely mainly on the natural powers
of the body to heal
and as is obvious this power lies
outside the direct control of the doctor
the Greek philosophers saw a similarity
in that respect with their own art which
was teaching
at The Last Resort the power to learn
does not lie with the teacher
no more than the power to heal with the
doctor
I can't make you learn anything
but you do learn
you learn because you want to learn
and in a certain sense what they were
saying is you you can rely on the body
to heal and just well sorry I can rely
on your intelligence to learn
and nature is the primary healer
at least that was the Greek
conviction
and a very important German philosopher
of medicine called Hans Georg gadamer
characterized healing as enigmatic on
that account
and perhaps we can apply the cinnamons
difficult to interpret
mysterious even
to amplify what jury was getting at now
I was going to talk to you a little
about a bit about interventionist
medicine and trace it back to um Francis
Bacon
and also to um
to a Descartes but I think you've
probably heard a lot about that but
basically these guys said intervene
intervene intervene get work get get
involved
with they all admitted that the current
science got you nowhere but this it had
a huge uh promissory value
and health would become the foundation
of all the other blessings in this life
said bacon
and what they were looking for was a
cure for incurable diseases
the enhancement of human capacity
the prolonging of life even and you know
these are still things where where we're
at
uh
and these promissory notes
were taken up over time
in the universities where as now I think
the medical faculties have a Primacy far
far greater than the arts and humanities
faculties
you know it's
that's how it's that's what's happened
now
this kind of philosophical reflection
privileging science has had many
consequences for Benson
the doctor or medical researcher are
portrayed as dealing with the body only
often modeled on a machine such that
machine is an extension of engineering
with the brain modeled on the computer
software to hardware
but there's always the feeling there's
something more
a more that features inescapably in the
interpersonal negotiation that is the
ancient and venerable medical interview
Stein entered into the
this um
debate
and in his earlier book he ends with
wherever one cannot speak therefore one
must be silent
you can speak science
but
the other things about which you cannot
speak
the appreciation of beauty
in Aesthetics
the values that are to be exemplified in
one's behavior in ethics
the Wonder at the very existence of the
world mysticism
in these cases all you can do he said at
that point
is is look
and point
look at that
feel that
that matters
later on he he modified that somewhat
with the notion of language games
but he was against which we've discussed
last day scientism and coming to an end
um
I'm sure he was influenced in his own
criticism of Science and remember he
started out like as an engineer
um
by his own experience of the mechanized
Slaughter in the trenches of the first
World War
the industrial scale extermination of
the Jews
a Heritage he could claim as his own
under the Nazis and after 1945 the
nuclear threat that still hangs over
mankind
with Mr guten
and all these are examples of the abuse
of science unforeseen by Descartes or
bacon
so
put it this way Wittgenstein and Drury
picked this up was an anti-cartesian
anti
seeing a huge separation between mind
and body
we are embodied beings
and near can the two be separated and
they're separated only at their
separation
gives an entree into science into areas
where I shouldn't go and can't go
nevertheless jewelry and with
wittgenstein's approval
we're welcomed the use of pharmacology
in Psychiatry which happened in the 19
50s I suppose
but
he rickenstein warned don't let yourself
think that all human problems can be
solved in this way they can't
Although our intelligence and our
willpower are dependent on the proper
functioning of a very complicated and
delicate neuro-humeral
mechanism over which we have no control
our sanity is at the mercy of a molecule
but that does not mean that all the
answers lie on that level of analysis
in mental illness during
uh stressed the terrifying loneliness of
the experience of mental illness
but he said our loneliness that can make
the sufferer more aware of the
mysteriousness of our present being
indeed the patient may thereby again
gain insights not yet appreciated by his
medical carer
as witkenstein remarked
to the patient in Saint Patrick's
Hospital
I think this man is much more
intelligent than any of his doctors
in some
mental illness can make the Enigma of
each person
apparent not only to the sufferer but
for those who care for him or her
especially perhaps the medical carer
and it is because of that Enigma with
its attendant uncertainty
that Medical Practice continues to be as
much an art as it is a science
this art can only be Mastered by an
onerous apprenticeship such as truly
experienced through that apprenticeship
the doctor learns when to intervene
using valuable scientific resources and
when to let nature take its healing
course
this discrimination is especially part
and important when the doctor faces his
or her last task
the palliative one of conducting the
patient
to the gates of the unknown at our death
thank you
foreign
[Music]